working as family does have its
challenges of course does everybody hit
if everyone's laughing but you know we
start together for the rest of our lives
this is true that was the Fab Four
speaking at the first royal foundation
forum in February 2018 but now we're
learning
there's nothing together about them
anymore working together as family do
you ever have disagreements about things
on Thursday Kensington Palace released a
statement announcing that Prince Harry
and Megan Markel are officially
splitting from Prince William and Kate
Middleton's charity the news comes one
day after a source told ET that the
split was expected to become official
this week the last thing you disagreed
on how to resolve it for the statement
the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge are
the winners of this theoretical custody
battle the royal foundation will become
their principal charitable and
philanthropic vehicle later this year
while the duke and duchess of sussex
will establish their own new charitable
foundation with transitional operating
support from the royal foundation but
this isn't totally goodbye so you both
take credit for coming up with the idea
takes me according to the palace
statement both couples will continue to
work together on projects in the future
this includes the Foundation's Mental
Health Program
heads together why has two different one
mental health it's a calling present
mental health sort of seem to run
between all the different we were
working according to the palace these
changes are designed to best complement
the work and responsibilities of their
Royal Highnesses as they prepare for
their future roles and to better align
their charitable activity with their new
households adding that both couples are
incredibly proud of what they've
achieved together through the Royal
Foundation
found uniting people together bringing
together made so much broke down
barriers that made things move much
quicker much smoother and actually we
got more impact from this as for what
the future of the foundation homes will
and Kate planned to build on the
Foundation's past successes which means
focusing on initiatives like heads
together United for wildlife and
mentally healthy schools they're also in
the process of developing new
initiatives on the environment and
support for children and families expect
updates on those in the coming year a
source told ET on Wednesday that the
split among the Royals and individual
charities was expected adding that there
are ongoing discussions about
disentangling the finances I think it
surprised all of us how much [ __ ] it
took off the royal foundation was set up
by William Kate and Harry in 2011 with
Megan making her first appearance at the
Forum in 2018 she officially joined the
organization last June following her
wedding to Prince Harry I think it's
absolutely the case that the brothers
did fall out I was told by a very senior
royal source that actually they weren't
talking to each other at one point of
course the split has once again sparked
the debate about a rift between the two
couples but royal expert Katie Nicol
tells ET that the Cambridge's and the
Sussex is actually seem to be getting
along better these days I certainly
think now that Archie is here um it has
probably really helped to improve the
relationship William is over the moon
that his brother is a dad Kate is very
broody she loves to be around newborns
and I hear that caters made herself
available to Megan if if she needs
advice if she needs any help
you